[Applause]
[Music]
one two three it's one day five o'clock
I'm your excellent host Wayne Campbell
and with me as usual is Gus party on
Wayne party on Garth and C all right
guys you've got a lot to cover this week
for our orbit report so let's get into
some trailers first up we wanted to talk
about the alien invasion someone trailer
that just came out starring you and
rayon from Game of Thrones misfits all
that good stuff it's about a man who
seems to be in an outpost kind of
guarding their world from aliens and
he's left alone serving his country and
gets a little cabin fever going on being
alone just with robots
it looks very intriguing an intriguing
take on sci-fi so I'm definitely
interested in watching it also he's a
really great actor so I'd like he could
hold his own alone in a film I think
mm-hmm you know sure so it's going to be
a limited release but that movie is
going to be available December 1st also
in trailers we got a Netflix original
post war drama named mud bound it looks
super dramatic almost like Oscar Beatty
dramatic in my opinion like it looks
super dramatic the newest trailer that
just dropped has a really interesting
song over it as well so you should
definitely watch that with the sound on
and but it looks really dramatic really
cool covering some heavy hitting topics
like PTSD and racial tensions post war
when you come home and still have
Klansmen and people telling you to enter
restaurants in the back door that's
awful
so I'm very excited to check that out
I'm gonna have to pick a day to
emotionally handle that but that's a
Netflix original movie and that'll
on November 17th yeah another Netflix
original movie that we got a trailer for
is bright which is a buddy-cop science
fiction fantasy film stars Will Smith
and he lives in a world where humans
live with orcs fairies elves all those
kind of fantasy characters and so Will
Smith is on the police force and he is
partnered with the first-ever orc police
officer who is played by Joel Edgerton
and this whole thing is actually
directed by David Ayer
I guess he worked with Will Smith in
Suicide Squad my god this is this is a
partnership that's lasting a lifetime um
it looks to be fairly interesting it
seems like it's playing out a lot of
buddy-cop
and fantasy tropes they get called in on
this call and then during the call they
find a magic wand which they say is a
nuclear weapon and it does kind of have
that Chloe load to it so then even I
believe Joel adjutants character says
something like we may be a part of a
prophecy we're not a part of a prophecy
so it seems like they go on this whole
adventure to protect the wand keep it
safe from different kinds of people and
they work together there's not so subtle
metaphors for orc and human racial
tensions so it seems fine I don't know
I'll still probably check it out but it
seems like it's gonna play on a lot of
tropes but if you're looking for a fun
action movie it could be something to
stream during Christmas vacation because
it's coming out on December 22nd on
Netflix great and another trailer that
we got this week was for an animated
Godzilla movie it's called gods yeah
there it is excellent thank you um it's
called Godzilla monster planet and this
is also going to be coming to Netflix
although we don't know when it's gonna
be released in Japan on November 17th
and the whole premise of this is that
Godzilla has basically taken over the
earth so humans leave they just GTFO too
many monsters they get out and then
there's a group of humans
that decide that they want to try to
come back and reclaim the earth and so
they do they come back and you see them
fighting Godzilla and other monsters
because he is the king of monsters so
there are other monsters involved here
the only kind of reservation I have
about it is it seems like this style is
a little odd but I mean of course it's
gonna be stylized in an anime but the
CGI blended with the animation seems a
little off at times but this is only the
trailer so I'm hoping good things to
come and again that's going to be Japan
in November 17th and the u.s. question
mark but Netflix it's picking some point
exactly we also got some casting news
this week the big one we saw a whole
bunch of casting coming out for Cobra
Kai which is YouTube bread's Karate Kid
that we talked about like months ago so
we finally have other casts
besides Daniel and then Johnny right um
the first cast we got is Cortney Hendler
who was on CBS's mom she is going to
play Daniels wife and partner in their
car dealership business because that's
just what all ex karate champions do
they own car dealerships and Mary Mouser
from NCIS and scandal is going to be
playing their daughter who is apparently
a super popular high school girl so we
even said maybe they'll flip the script
a little bit and she'll be the mean one
we'll see then Zolo marred when a' from
parenthood is going to be playing a
bullied high school student who kind of
seeks knowledge and refuge at the Cobra
Kai dojo wants to learn how to defend
himself against the bullies then Tanner
Tanner Buchanan of designated survivor
is going to be playing Johnny's son then
one of the few character descriptions we
got for him is that he is just trying to
do his best to not make the same
mistakes that his father did so again
maybe they'll be flipping the script on
that one and then the last casting news
we got about
that was Ed Asner is going to be
Johnny's disapproving stepfather thank
God I was hoping it was gonna be nice
yeah whoa we needed that load off my
mind again it's gonna be a sitcom yeah
some of these have tiny they're oh
pretty much layering that up they're in
there they're in there
we'll see how it goes again it's gonna
be on YouTube red sometime in 2018 they
still don't have a really safe 2018
YouTube red we can wait okay we're ready
in other casting news we've got a Shazam
a solo film should Zachary Levi of a
Chuck and of Thor which is what I know
I'm from cuz I'm sorry I don't watch
check so I know there's only so many
hours in a day you guys I've got to draw
the line somewhere somewhere he's going
to be playing the title role of the film
no news on if there's going to be a
young Billy oh no I mean I was hoping I
don't know how you got it but um yeah
but like we don't know what the casting
is gonna be there yet but we do know
that that for Levi is going to be
playing the lead and what's up with
Black Adam he's cast but he's not really
supposedly so at least not yet that
could change but like mm-hmm
who else he would fight another solo
comic book movie character that we have
coming to the big screens huh is a
Deathstroke apparently getting his own
movie he was initially supposed to be a
part of the Batman he was going to be
the main villain of the Batman we knew
that we had him cast as Joe mangly only
and now he's got his own movie he
tweeted a picture of the Deathstroke
mask
oh yeah well I you know um right now we
have Gareth Evans in discussions to
maybe direct it there is a script in
process but nothing has been confirmed
except that yeah he's getting his own
movie now that's exciting though I'd be
cool yeah especially likely from second
second fiddle to like main title
fill in your own that's pretty sweet
yeah yeah I mean and Slade Wilson is an
interesting character we could delve
into that world a little bit yeah
absolutely
the last thing we definitely wanted to
touch on is don't worry Michael Bay
isn't personally producing Dorothy
Explorer
however his production company Platinum
Dunes is it's his partners that are
producing it so it's technically like it
there still could be something happening
but it's going to be directed by Nick
Stoller and I'm sure you're all stoke
did a live-action Dora the Explorer
movie that Heather where can people find
you on social media you can find me on
Twitter at Heather roost Instagram I'm
at a truce or twitch twitch TV slash
other works and as usual you can find me
on Facebook as Ayanna wade or everywhere
else at awesome Ayanna so party on we're
gonna get on here okay so ready and
[Applause]
you